[Musique]
Stéphanie Grammont qui était à Ottawa
Chantal Hébert Michel COG bonsoir
bonsoir
on le dit beaucoup un budget c'est une
c'est une session des décisions des
choix politiques une vision
tour de table rapide après je vais vous
faire entendre les chèvres de position
puis la ministre mais d'abord un premier
tour de table sur vos premières
impressions des choix qui ont été faits
justement par la ministre en troisième
budget déposé Stéphanie Grandmont je
commence avec vous
mais je dirais que oui évidemment c'est
un budget qui était signé par Madame
freezing mais ça pourrait être aussi
presque un budget signé par Joe Biden
parce que on sent vraiment l'ombre des
États-Unis sur ce budget là étant donné
que les Américains avaient lancé un plan
énorme pour stimuler l'économie
l'économie verte et les entreprises
propres mais le Canada c'est c'est vu
obligé de faire un peu de limiter et
donc il y a 83 milliards sur 11 ans qui
sont débloqués pour que nos entreprises
restent concurrentielles face à ce
plan-là aux États-Unis donc c'est
beaucoup d'argent le Canada avait pas le
choix mais en même temps ça va coûter
cher c'est le gros morceau qu'on va voir
le tableau 4 on a un tableau nous c'est
80 sur 10 ans mais c'était énorme les
Américains ont annoncé 374 milliards je
croise au Ferrer sur 10 ans donc 80 pour
le Canada qui est dix fois plus petit
c'est beaucoup est-ce que ça vous a
surpris Stéphanie un petit mot là-dessus
encore l'ampleur de cette enveloppe si
je peux dire
mais c'est beaucoup d'argent surtout que
nous au Canada contrairement aux
Etats-Unis on a en plus le marché du
carbone ou la taxe carbone dépendante
des provinces donc ça aussi ce sont des
mesures qui font en sorte qu'on stimule
ou qu'on agit sur le les énergies
propres pour favoriser l'émergence de ce
secteur-là donc oui c'est beaucoup
d'argent et les Canada est parti un peu
tout azimut alors qu'on aurait peut-être
imaginé des mesures plus ciblées parce
qu'on peut pas nécessairement être
excellent et performé dans tout mais
quand même on a on a une intervention
d'une grande ampleur Chantal est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord c'est le gros morceau
du budget Freeland
je suis d'accord et je suis d'accord
aussi avec l'idée que Joe Biden est un
des coût auteurs de ce budget mais il y
a un deuxième côté et cette personne-là
s'appelle pas non plus
de tout évidence
j'avais parlé de toi mais moi je pense
qu'on parle plus de nécessité nécessité
de répondre en tout cas dans l'esprit du
gouvernement au plan Biden est nécessité
de satisfaire de la cuisine si vous
pensez que Justin Trudeau des élections
il suffit de lire le budget pour
comprendre que non il y a des gros
morceaux dans l'esprit du NPD
certainement et entre autres ce
programme d'assurance dentaire qui qui
va plus vite que la plupart des
observateurs
s'y attendaient les mesures pour contrer
l'inflation et dans le plan sur les
énergies vertes la prescription qu'il
faut aussi qu'on offre des bons salaires
des salaires syndiqués que Monsieur
alors je dirais que
je cherche madame Freeland là-dedans et
je trouve Joe Biden et doc meeting mais
je ne la trouve pas vraiment
soin dentaire c'est 13 milliards sur
cinq ans on a ajouté à 8 milliards je
crois Michel C on a parlé plutôt
ensemble
c'est
dépensier bon la ministre en défend je
voulais faire entendre tout à l'heure
mais
dépensier dans la mesure où le 80
milliards est imposant les dames c'est
pour le lien avec le NPD on aide aussi
les gens avec un crédit additionné pour
la retour de tps remboursement de tps
qui va coûter à peu près 3 milliards et
on repousse donc
en fait on repousse tellement qu'on ne
le voit plus le retour à l'équilibre
budgétaire
non effectivement c'est il faut vraiment
voir la différence entre budget une
budget qu'on a vu la semaine dernière à
Québec parce que c'est c'est le jour et
la nuit il y a des dépenses très
structurales tout ce qui mis sur
l'économie verte c'est pas gaspiller
mais je pense pas que ça ne sera
est très structurant et on peut dire que
le plan dentaire c'est quelque chose qui
pour en terme de santé et quelque chose
d'important c'est un investisseur aussi
dans l'avenir mais pas de baisse
d'impôts par exemple là-dedans il y a
pas de retour à l'équilibre budgétaire
alors
et à Québec on disait 55 ans les chances
d'une récession à Ottawa aux ivrons
d'abord une répression modeste sur on
s'en va là-dedans en 2023 alors il
faudra voir comment on sort de tout ça
mais il est clair que
on avait un plat on avait des objectifs
très précis et
il faudra voir maintenant si ces
investissements là dans l'économie vont
rapporter puis vont avoir les fesses sur
l'économie commerciale sur le sur le
résultat de tout ça donc éloignement du
retour à Lille aux déficit de zéro
Stéphanie sur le la dette qui prend de
l'ampleur un milliard 300 à 100.000 100
sans rien en 1300 milliards je vais
finir par le dire ça c'est la ratio PIB
que vous voyez donc 39.9 presque 40
est-ce que ça ça inquiétait les gens
vous étiez au huis clos est-ce que ça
étonne où on se dit quand on se compare
finalement on n'est pas si pire
mais vraiment je pense que si il y a il
y a quand même une préoccupation c'est
un gros problème du budget en fait des
derniers budgets des libéraux c'est
qu'on sent qu'il dépense et ils
accumulent déficit par-dessus des
ficides juste pour vous donner une idée
Patrice depuis 2021 seulement donc on
oublie la pandémie donc depuis 2021
libéraux ont annoncé 350 milliards
pratiquement de nouvelles dépenses sur
cinq ans et ça ça inclut 43 milliards
dans le dans le budget d'aujourd'hui
donc c'est beaucoup d'argent la pandémie
on pouvait comprendre que c'était
nécessaire d'intervenir mais là toutes
ces dépenses là est-ce qu'elles étaient
toutes absolument essentielles
aujourd'hui maintenant c'est sûr que des
services de garde des soins dentaires
l'Ukraine etc on a toutes sortes de
bonnes raisons mais quand on accumule
tout ça ça fait beaucoup d'argent et le
la teinte de du surplus c'est un peu
comme un mirage qui finit toujours par
disparaître quand on pense y arriver
donc dans les non-ci budgétaires là de
l'automne dernier on disait ah oui on va
y être dans 6 ans on pensait avoir un
surplus de 4,5 milliards mais là ah des
nouvelles dépenses encore et puis
l'économie tourne un peu moins vite mais
finalement on va avoir un déficit de 14
milliards dans dans
5 ans en 27 28 alors on voit que le
déficit est persiste et puis même la
dette on voit le fameux ratio d'être PIB
que le gouvernement là nous avait servi
comme ancrage en disant écoutez ça
diminue c'est ça qui est important mais
là on voit que ça va augmenter et ce qui
est encore plus important je trouve
c'est que les frais d'intérêt qu'on paye
à chaque année le les taux d'intérêt
remonte alors qu'est-ce qui se passe au
lieu d'avoir à peu près 25 milliards de
paiement d'intérêt là dans trois ans ça
va être plutôt 46 milliards c'est que ça
va pratiquement doubler c'est
significatif on en fera des choses avec
cet argent-là si on n'avait pas à payer
la carte de crédit qu'on a rempli
tranquillement comme ça Chantal et
Michel Stéphanie résume bien
l'inquiétude de beaucoup d'économistes
déjà à qui on parle depuis 16 ans est-ce
que politiquement ça rend d'après vous
le gouvernement Trudeau plus vulnérable
devant les conservateurs que ces
dépenses où il y a assez d'alliés puis
comment vous voyez l'équation Chantale
le gouvernement est changé sa survit à
court terme pour des difficultés
possibles en campagne électorale les
sondages montrent déjà une majorité des
lecteurs je suis pas en train de parler
juste de conservateur une majorité des
lecteurs donnent des mauvais points au
gouvernement pour sa gestion de
l'économie donc sur ce tableau là les
conservateurs demandent dans à peu près
toutes les franges des vecteurs les
libéraux sur le plan de la gestion là on
leur dit les déficits c'était pas
important pour nous et ça a bien passé
depuis 2015 mais on leur dit aussi
l'encrage qu'on avait établi si c'est un
bateau le Canada on vient de réduire
mais Nathan qu'on va la laisser flotter
un peu plus loin puis après on verra si
on réussit à la remettre dans le fond
c'est quand même particulier comme
message et ce qui est inquiétant là
dedans pour ceux d'entre nous qui ont
couvert la période 90 à 2000 et le
déficit fédéral de l'époque et Paul
Martin c'est que beaucoup des postes de
dépenses dont on parle on n'est plus en
pandémie là c'est pas des programmes
ponctuels c'est des dépenses récurrentes
pour la santé pour le programme de garde
d'enfants pour les soins dentaires
faites la liste donc ça veut dire que ce
sont des dépenses à moins qu'on fasse
disparaître des programmes ce sont des
dépenses qui vont revenir ou bien comme
dans l'ancien temps qu'on va tout à coup
transférer uneilatéralement au province
et Michel vous l'avez souligné tout à
l'heure tout ça alors que de la bouche
même de la ministre on dit 2023 là il y
aura à peu près pas de croissance
et c'est ça qui risque d'être le
problème c'est parce que là on n'est pas
encore dans un budget pré électoral elle
sera beaucoup plus dans le budget de
l'année prochaine mais qu'elle va être
l'état de l'économie quotidienne à ce
moment-là est-ce qu'on pourra se prévoir
80 milliards mais est-ce qu'on pourra
aller jusqu'au bout de ça et d'autre
part à un moment donné dire ce sont
structurant qu'on
prépare l'avenir à long terme c'est plus
difficile à vendre dans une campagne
électorale que le court terme alors
c'est ça qu'il va falloir voir sur la
est-ce que les gens vont comprendre
l'importance de l'économie verte
structurantes qu'on veut y mettre
maintenant ou bien s'ils vont dire
dans ma situation financière c'est une
grande commentaire on voit pas la plante
tout de suite là un mot sur ce qui
touche vraiment les quelqu'un qui
gagnent moins de 49.000 très concrets on
va voir le tableau paiement unique pour
l'épicerie on en parle depuis tout à
l'heure là Stéphanie qu'en pensez-vous
parce qu'au Québec on avait dit les
chèques à tout le monde je pense que
vous aviez écrit ça d'ailleurs vous êtes
beaucoup d'autres les chaque à tout le
monde c'est pas une bonne idée il faut
cibler à ceux qui ont davantage besoin
là aussi qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
parce que effectivement l'inflation à
l'épice à l'épicerie particulièrement
qui restent élevé ça fait mal à qui ça
fait mal particulièrement aux gens plus
vulnérables qui eux peuvent pas couper
ailleurs il y a pas de discrétionnaire
donc c'est eux qui faut aider et puis de
faire des baisses d'impôts oui c'est
vendeur c'est électoralisme mais des
baisses d'impôts généralisées ça ça
attise encore plus l'inflation donc
c'est pas le moment de faire ça et donc
vaut mieux y aller avec une approche
ciblée et là dessus je pense que Ottawa
était raisonnable et c'est gardé de
mettre de l'huile sur le feu très bien
je vous avais dit qu'on attendait la
ministre on va entendre la ministre sur
son plan en verre de 80 milliards et les
chefs de l'opposition et on revient tout
de suite
c'est le Canada qui a commencé ses
actions très très fort pour
bâtir l'économie propre c'est le Canada
qui a mis une prix sur la pollution une
grande
décision et une des décisions les plus
importantes d'une autre gouvernement et
le Canada a commencé avec cette décision
de faire des grandes investissements
chaque année avec chaque budget
3 milliards de dollars de dépenses
additionnelles qui va être payé en taxe
et pour il ne met pas en place les
mesures préventives qui permettraient à
l'économie du Canada et du Québec d'être
prêt encore de récession on va appuyer
le budget donc on est fier du fait que
les sondage sont là on est fiers de fait
que on a forcé ce gouvernement de mettre
le plus d'argent dans les projets on est
fier de tout ça mais en même temps on
n'est pas satisfait avec les montes des
actions pour la crise du logement et
manque des actions pour
améliorer la science emploi
bon je reviens monsieur signe il fallait
qu'il se garde une petite gêne en disant
on aurait voulu voir d'autres mesures
pour le logement mais il est son sourire
son visage était éclatant de joie là
Michel c'est un budget coécrit avec le
NPD
oui
ça veut dire certainement de choses y
compris le plan dentaire etc mais pour
Monsieur saigne c'est le pari qu'il a
fait le danger toujours le même pour les
vidéos démocrates c'est leurs électeurs
s'en aille au libéraux si on perd les
conservateurs gagnent lui au moins pour
dire mais moi j'ai fait le plan dentaire
puis il serait pas là si j'avais pas été
là alors c'est le père qui fait et son
pari reflète dans le budget ça c'est
vrai j'entends c'est comme s'il disait
moi j'aurais laissé ça au Canadiens peu
importe ce qui arrive à une la
prochaine fois là
présumant évidemment que on va trouver
une façon de livrer la marchandise
annoncées aujourd'hui parce que je serai
présent il y a pas de province qui sont
présentés en disant nous on veut
vraiment aider à gérer structurer ce
plan-là premier problème deuxièmement
oui monsieur signe célèbre aujourd'hui
en principe il reste au moins un autre
budget avant que son entente avait
Justin Trudeau arrive à terme moi j'ai
l'impression que la facture commence à
être salée puis que c'est ça va avoir
été son meilleur budget et c'est ça et
que même les libéraux pourront pas
suivre Stéphanie même les libéraux qui
sont capables de dépenser vous l'avez
dit pourront pas suivre le rythme
m'emmener là
parce qu'il y a encore beaucoup d'autres
demandes il y avait été question le NPD
parlait d'un programme d'assurance
médicament après ça il y a les
États-Unis on en parlait le Joe Biden
était au Canada la semaine dernière
c'est sur les certains que eux ils ont
toujours la même demande de dire est-ce
que le Canada pourra augmenter ses
dépenses militaires à 2 % du PIB c'est
la recommandation de l'OTAN et puis on
est loin de ça on est autour de un point
1,3 là il y avait rien neuf dans le
budget là-dessus donc il y a d'autres
demandes ça va continuer à s'accumuler
et puis face à ça oui les libéraux
restent d'avoir encore à dépenser
d'autres argent mais là il y a des
limites puis dans un dans le cadre d'un
gouvernement minoritaire c'est un peu
seul défaut c'est qu'on constate que
pour faire des compromis ça coûte
toujours plus cher et donc ça fait en
sorte que ces gouvernements-là sont plus
dépensés il y a une spirale avant de
vous quitter on a lors de notre marathon
vendredi Chantal et Michel C
on a parlé beaucoup de défense et des
soins exprimés depuis des 40 ans 50 ans
par les Américains que le Canada fasse
plus or petite surprise pour ma part je
vous avoue j'étais pas dans le huis clos
mais
il y a pas de réinvestissement massif du
tout on va ajuster un peu un budget pour
le la modernisation du nomade Chantal ça
vous étonne
totalement mais s'il y avait eu un
réinvestissement massif je te demande à
quelle hauteur le déficit pour les
prochaines années en réalité mais on
comprend mieux maintenant pourquoi la
date du budget Freeland judicieusement
été choisi pour tomber quelques jours
après le départ de Monsieur Biden plutôt
que justement il a été gentil monsieur
baiden maison
parce que les Américains vont toujours
dire c'est ça vous mettez moins en
défense parce que vous savez qu'on va
vous protéger et puis nous on dépense et
vous vous avez des vous payez des
programmes sociaux plus généreux alors
il y a cette insatisfaction là de la
part des Américains mais je dirais de
manière plus générale c'est que je pense
que les libéraux dépensent beaucoup et
qui serait temps pour eux de pour le
Canada d'avoir des points d'ancrage
budgétaire beaucoup plus solide parce
que c'est le cas on le vu au Québec on
s'est doté de loi sur le déficit de la
dette etc ça a donné des résultats
remarquables
Ottawa devrait faire la même chose et la
plupart des pays de l'OCDE ont déjà ce
genre de mesure là dans leur loi très
claire Michel mot de la fin très rapide
il y a une chose qui qu'on ne pourra pas
hésiter c'est la modernisation de
florale ça des Américains Étienne il y a
presque pas d'argent il y a des femmes
mineurs
il va falloir quelque part l'année
prochaine
merci beaucoup bonne soirée à très
bientôt au revoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI